لو تحدثني عن خططكم المستقبليه مستقبلا
كيف ترون منظمتكم ماذا تريدون ما هو الهدف
الذي الذي تريدون تحقيقه
منظمتنا مهيكله الان لتحديد حاجيات اطفال
فلسطين وايضا منطقه الشرق الاوسط مثل ما
شرحنا ذلك من قبل لقد ذهبنا على القيام
بذلك منذ 30 عاما ستطلق منظمتنا برامج
اخرى وستستمر في تنفيذ برامجها الحاليه
على الارض لسد حاجات الناس لقد وفرنا
مراكز عنايه من السرطان عندما لم تكن
الضفه الغربيه تتوفر ولو على مركز وحيد من
هذا النوع لقد بنينا اثنين بفضل تبرعات من
مختلف انحاء العالم بنينا مراكز عنايه
مركزه ومراكز قلب لقد انشانا شبكه من مئات
المتطوعين الطبيين في عام واحد وفي ذلك
العام اطلقنا 150 مهمه طبيه وتمريضيه من
متطوعين من فرنسا والمانيا وامريكا
ونيوزيلن واليابان وغيرها عرب وغير عرب
كلهم ساعدوا الاف الاطفال بظروف صحيه
مختلفه سنستمر في تنميه وتوسيع برامجنا
ومساعده شرائح اكثر من الاطفال وانقاذ
مزيدا من الحوات ونقل مزيد من الاطفال
للخارج للعلاج بتوحيد جهد الناس فعندما
يكون طفل بحاجه الى المساعده لا يوجد اي
معنى لان تكون فلسطينيا او امريكيا او
اماراتيا نحن كلنا بشر لا يوجد مسلم او
مسيحي عندما يكون هناك طفل يتالم بحاجه
الى عمليه جراحيه او تدخل طبي ينبغي ان
نتذكر دوما اننا كلنا انسان وينبغي ان
نساعد بعضنا البعض باقصى ما يمكن من اللطف
والخير والعطف والحنان وان نعمل على
مداواه بعضنا البعض هذا هو الطريق الوحيد
للبقاء ولحصول الشعب الفلسطيني على حريته